Do you know peter parker who's spider-man yes is
that him no can you please explain what is going
on after i shut that spell down we started getting
visitors from every universe multiverse is real
i need you to capture them before they destroy
the fabric of reality i'm gonna need some help
you guys ready let's catch some multiverse men
spider-man your way home what was
your name again doctor otto octavius
seriously what's your actual name
Welcome back everyone happy thanksgiving this is
gonna be my new spider-man no way home trailer
video there's a bunch of new footage and they give
us a bunch of details about what's happening with
the multiverse during this movie as we head into
doctor strange 2 we also have to give thanks for
this amazing new meme format that they've given
us do you know peter parker who's spider-man yes
is that him no is that him no is that him no is
that him no is that him no is that him yes if
you're brand new to the channel i do marvel videos
every week be sure to subscribe to get everything
we also just started doing hawkeye episodes and
i just posted my episode 1 in episode 2 video so
i'll have links for that down in the description
below and at the end of this but during this new
trailer footage doctor strange and spider-man have
captured doctor octopus in the basement of the
sanctum in that special prison cell and they've
started to work out all the damage from the
multiverse spell spider-man is still struggling
to understand exactly how bad this is and as
funny as this new meme format is it's also kind of
funny that both doctor strange and doctor octopus
doctors geniuses within the respective fields are
both struggling to explain the multiverse to peter
like doctor octopus isn't technically a villain
anymore at the end of spider-man 2 but for the
sake of argument the way they're playing him in
this big bridge fight scene makes it sound like
he starts the movie as a villain so even one
of the villains is having to give spider-man
a tutorial in the spider-verse during my last
couple of spider-man videos i've already talked
about the theory the doctor octopus isn't actually
a villain during the movie like he actively tries
to help spider-man fix this problem where what
the sinister six characters are doing threatens
to destroy all of reality but they have all these
great tobey maguire moments and jokes during these
scenes like it kind of starts during the actual
bridge fight where peter takes his iron spider
mask off and doctor octopus is like wait what
you're not peter parker thinking that during
that whole fight that they were having he'd been
fighting toby maguire spider-man and that's why
he says you think your fancy new suit is going to
save you in jokes to his octopus arms about how
they're having a competition to see who has the
most arms when he busts out the iron spider legs
it wouldn't be a spider-man movie if spider-man
wasn't confused about every single thing that
was happening but when they're back at the sanctum
both doctors explained the multiverse to him again
and that's probably where we get that scene of
him saying wait the multiverse is real which is
a big callback to spider-man far from home with
mysterio in his explainer for the multiverse
because mysterio was lying about a bunch of things
but even when that first movie came out we saw
that scene anyone who's ever read a single
marvel comic book or seen a couple of movies
could probably tell you that the concept of the
multiverse was real it was just that mysterio was
only lying about his specific backstory within the
multiverse and those elemental monsters he created
based on the classic spider-man villains but the
whole time the multiverse was real kevin feige
even said that when they debuted doctor strange 2
multiverse of madison comic-con a couple years ago
just because quentin beck makes up lies about
the multiverse doesn't mean it isn't real i
think there were a lot of younger fans who maybe
just hadn't seen a lot of movies period or hadn't
read a lot of the marvel comics made the wrong
assumption after the movie that because mysterio
was lying he was lying about everything and there
was some confusion after the loki series with he
who remains kang in the way he was manipulating
the main mcu timeline so that it was the only
timeline in all of existence like wait a minute
how could he have been manipulating things that
way but there was still a multiverse what's
the difference so if you're still confused
about what he who remains was doing and whether
or not there was a multiverse before the loki
series before silvi killed him freed all the kang
variants and infinite timelines started to grow
back across the multiverse the way the marvel
people are explaining this is that there was
always a multiverse even before the loki series
gave us all that kang multiverse war backstory
in the loki people were using the concept of
alternate timelines with these kang variants
is a separate concept from alternate universes
and alternate dimensions so this is actually
really important all those different things are
completely different concepts alternate timelines
are not the same thing as alternate dimensions
or alternate universes the loki series was mostly
about the kang multiverse war as it applied
to alternate timelines you know per this miss
minutes tva tutorial the only time that they
would intervene to shut down a branch timeline
was when they detected that it would give rise
to a dangerous kang variant and what happens
when a branch timeline goes past redline is that
it turns into a fully alternate reality so when
he who remains was controlling the sacred timeline
there still were fully alternate realities growing
just only ones where there were not dangerous
king variants when you see the sacred timeline
here they show it for real it's depicted kind of
like a giant rope arcing through space the rope
explainer's actually really good one a rope is
created for many strands of smaller ropes woven
together think of the sacred timeline as being
a collection of many smaller timelines that are
each very similar and all these strands represent
the collection of alternate timelines where he
who remains the supreme and the only version of
kang who comes to power and he who remains was
controlling the sacred timeline for all the marvel
infinity saga movies iron man to avengers end game
also technically eternals too because that takes
place at the beginning of the timeline like the
birth of the main mcu universe so he who remains
did allow the celestials to continue doing what
they were doing during that movie and during the
first doctor strange movie during marvel phase 2
the ancient one speaks of the multiverse and
sends doctor strange on a cosmic tour of it he
passes through many many alternate dimensions
each one more dangerous than the last so while
he's on this tour of the multiverse he's doing it
within the sacred timeline and what that means is
that marvel is just using the term multiverse to
loosely describe a couple of different concepts
alternate dimensions alternate universes now
alternate timelines with all the kang variants
so the multiverse has always existed it was just
that he who remains was limiting the subset of
timelines where his kang variants came to power
like everybody's cool everybody can do whatever
they want just not you other versions of kang and
during this new spider-man no way home trailer
doctor strange also tells peter this is really
important the scooby-doo gang that they have
to capture the other sinister six characters
before they destroy the fabric of all reality
the entire multiverse so no pressure spider-man
what that means is that willem dafoe's green
goblin jamie foxx's electro sandman the lizard are
doing something that makes whatever spider-man did
to mess the spell up even worse and we're watching
it play out in this statue of liberty scene where
doctor strange is staring at the sky tearing with
those huge purple gashes those are literal tears
in the fabric of reality you can kind of tell
this is happening after spider-man's big battle
with all the villains because the giant captain
america shield has already fallen to the ground
there's this rubble all around the statue of
liberty so it's after their big final boss fight
but talking more about big threats from beyond
our main mcu universe main dimension and getting
into doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness plot
the main job of the sorcerer's supreme of doctor
strange is to protect the main mcu reality that's
what he was joking with iron man about during
avengers infinity war what's your job exactly what
is your job exactly besides making balloon animals
protecting your reality douchebag he's supposed
to protect the main mcu reality from all threats
within our reality and threats from outside our
reality threats like dormammu and he's only one of
many many cosmic villains that are super powerful
that exist outside the main mcu dimension the
next best example a lot of you probably already
connected these dots is the dweller in darkness
from the shangshi movie even though he destroyed
the talo dimension where shengshi's mother and
her people came from the dweller in darkness
itself did not originate in their dimension
it came from a dimension called Everinnye and
it's one of the marvel fear lords it was born as
the physical manifestation of people's collective
fears like people's collective fear made it into a
real thing and then like dormammu it went around
breaking into other people's dimensions sucking
the souls out of all living beings and moving on
to the next dimension and it was doing that while
he who remains was controlling the sacred timeline
breaking around to a bunch of different dimensions
you may have heard that scarlet witch is kind of
supposed to be one of the main villains of doctor
strange 2 but i believe the schuma goreth is
supposed to be the actual main villain or secret
main villain however you want to think about it
he is part of a group of creatures that are called
the many angled ones who were born in the chaos
of nothingness that existed before the big bang
one of his other names is the lord of chaos the
darkhold is connected to chaos magic scarlet witch
uses chaos magic now you start to see how
everything is connected schumachorth mostly
exists in the space between dimensions and he's
one of the most powerful elder gods he's like
a very cthulu version of a marvel elder god an
eldritch horror who used to rule over the main
mcu dimension millions of years ago until he was
banished to the space between dimensions and along
comes the spider-man to botch doctor strange's
spell then the sinister six characters also trying
to break the fabric of all reality just creating
these tears in reality between dimensions and it
seems like the perfect opportunity for him to come
back and what scarlet witch is doing during that
movie makes things even worse spider-man no way
home kind of shows you that a bunch of people and
things from alternate universes like alternate
versions of spider-man toby maguire andrew
garfield their villains are combining in this main
mcu universe because of doctor strange's spell
scarlet witch is trying to bring her children
billy and tommy back doing something not too
dissimilar like scramble reality in a way that
will bring her children back using her chaos
magic in the dark hold so she's manipulating the
multiverse in a really dangerous way that's not
too dissimilar from what's happening in spider-man
no way home same basic problem different day just
another day in the life of the doctor strange
sorcerer supreme trying to stop all these marvel
heroes from breaking all of reality but everyone
let me know in the comments how do you think that
spider-man no way home will help set up doctor
strange 2 there'll be a bunch more trailers in the
next couple of weeks so if you have any special
requests just leave them in the comments below
or big questions that i didn't answer in this
video my full hawkeye episode 3 video will post
next week you can click here for my full hawkeye
episode 1 in episode 2 video as well so be sure to
check those out thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and happy thanksgiving!